all right I'm going to uh uh call to
order the uh uh executive session of the
uh Judiciary Committee and I guess I
would begin by asking everyone to stand
Allegiance I PL allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liy and
justice for
all thank
you um so um as you know from the agenda
we have only one uh bill that we're
going to be executing today U but we
because of a traffic problems we have
several Representatives who are are in
route but are not here yet um so
uh what I'd like to do is I've
circulated to the members and also there
are copies available for the public um
2463 um which is I think the the the
amendment that we're going to be taking
up and discussing and my question first
to the members of the committee who are
here does anybody have any questions uh
concerns anything like that you want to
matter representative stapled thank you
Mr
chair um in reviewing some of
the testimony um I came across two that
were submitted to us uh via email one
from the National Insurance crime
Bureau and one from the business and
industry Association both are opposed to
uh
hb314 um just as a a quick excerpt
review House Bill 314 the nicb wres
seeks to restrict information sharing
with government entities even for the
purposes of investigation and
prosecution of criminal cases by state
or local law enforcement
agencies The Bill runs counter to the
express goals of the fraud reporting
statutes referenced above and would
restrict nicb ability to provide
information to New Hampshire state and
local law enforcement in order to help
protect New
Hampshire new hampshirites who are
victims of insurance crimes that's the
nicb the Bia business and industry
Association excerp here Bia has strongly
opposed HB 314 from the start
particularly because of its inclusion of
third-party providers and contractors
that extend coverage to non-government
entities despite the Bill's original
intent amendments to hb314 have made the
bill worse and the best thing is to kill
it so the Committees can concentrate on
S SP 255 the model consumer privacy
legislation already passed in 13
States hb314 was Rewritten with no
apparent study on potential negative
consequences so those two pieces give me
some concern and wonder if there's other
commentaries to counter
those well thank you very much for the
question I think um first with regard to
um the the uh is it nicb the insurance
industry uh their their uh comment I did
specifically have an email exchange with
um is it Mr who's who's the person that
signed the
letter Mr Hand I did have an email
exchange with Mr Hand and that in fact
is this his concern which I thought was
a very very valid point was the the
specific reason that on line
29 of the bill I added the language at
the beginning unless specifically
authorized by law because he pointed out
in his um in his letter or maybe in the
the attached the statement that was
attached to the letter that there are
actually some New Hampshire statutes
that direct insurance companies to
provide to disclose information in
certain circumstances where there are uh
where there's uh fraud or or allegations
of fraud so that
specifically is is addressed and when I
sent it to him he responded saying you
know that oh good that's that you know
that that addresses Our concern um the
other the other um more broadly and I
and I think this at least I hope I'm not
positive but I hope this addresses the
concern of the ba also is that we also
added in on beginning on page two on
line three in that subsection B we added
language to say that a third-party
provider of information May disclose it
um where it has reason to believe that
the disclosure is necessary to prevent
or detect uh criminal conduct fraudulent
conduct identity theft uh harassment or
other activity and so I I mean it it
seems to
me with the with the provisions that
I've
discussed we really
have granted th this proposal
grants exceptions to allow
disclosure whenever it's really Whenever
there are reasons to allow disclosure
and I think it it it it's you know it
the bill is not stingy in allowing
disclosures to be made when there's some
reason to allow the disclosure so I
think with that it it really is sound
public policy and I think consistent
with the recent Constitutional Amendment
we've had in New Hampshire to say that
with with that um with those exceptions
allowing disclosure it does make sense
to say if you don't fit in with those
dis if you don't fit into those
exceptions then you can't
disclose um and that because that it's
necessary to protect privacy um and I
you know the the other point that I
would make I think this is really
important point to make is remember
unlike
255 this this is a disclosure Bill only
this doesn't say anything about the
ability of anybody to collect
information that's that those
restrictions are in 255 to the extent
that they exist and they and I mean
there are some pretty significant
restrictions in 255 but this bill
doesn't say anything about anybody
collecting information um that the only
thing that it prohibits is the
disclosure so the you know an insurance
company or a bank or whatever uh if
they're prohibited from collecting
information it's not by this bill it's
by 255 or maybe some other you know
Federal statutes or whatever all this
bill says is if the bank as an example
or the insurance company has information
personal information on you or me or or
whoever they can't disclose it unless
they meet the requirements of this bill
and as I said I think that the the the
the bill allows disclosure in all of the
circumstances in which there's a reason
for disclosure what it it seems to me
that the you know the the central thing
that this bill will prohibit which is I
think what um what representative former
representative Kirk and representative
Earth were particularly concerned about
and I share their concern is to prohibit
the the the one of the things it doesn't
say in here is a good reason for for
disclosure is you want to sell the
information an insurance company wants
to sell the information to to some third
party to for a profit they can't do that
unless unless the unless you as a
consumer specifically consent to it and
I think that's you know that's entirely
the way it should be um so anyway uh
representative Smith if you wanted to
comment
also no I think you did a an an
excellent job Mr chair and I also would
like to thank our colleague for raising
these questions because you know they're
out there in The Ether and it's very
this is very complex I I'll say
again we have no business doing this it
should be done in Washington but
Washington has not been able to find a
way to move forward and by what we're
doing here
today I think is I hope and what we will
do by June is adding one more state to
the many states that are saying the same
thing I mean not necessarily the same
exact word but saying this is an
important issue and if you're not going
to act we're going to we're going to do
something um and I hope in the end we
will have
some certainly not this year but maybe
in the next couple of
years some standard language coming from
the federal government but we've tried
very hard to walk a very narrow line
here
to respect uh um to respect the
capitalist
system and also respect what New
Hampshire residents citizens think is
very important and that is
privacy um but I think it's it's good
that you raise those questions
um and I appreciate the uh the chair's
comments um while I have my light on um
we have now had confirmation that
representative MC Beth will not be here
um so we do um Shelly is on the way but
when you are ready to call for emersion
you should just go ahead because um it's
not fair to keep everybody waiting too
long well no well well thank you U
representative Smith and I I not I I I
think I did hear representative Kenny
indicate that he has a class at 11 so I
don't that I think In fairness to him
that we make make sense to to he wasn't
brave enough to tell me
that it may make sense to move to move
uh forward so um all right so um is
there any further uh
discussion representative orgon mean I
still have some doubts about this bill I
mean certainly it does uh send a message
and um it's the greatly improved over
the original bill but I'm just as
somebody who's been involved in um
providing online services and also
hosting online communities there's seems
there some
legitimate um reasons why
uh The Operators you know the hosts and
operators would want to know the
real life identity the person and
sometime even share it even when it's
mostly being done anonymously and
there's reasons Beyond simply harassment
and fraud while you might want to uh
reveal something is and you certainly uh
want to know who you're dealing with
especially if there's a especially if
you're engaging in financial dealings
with them too so I I
um so I'm not sure whether it's I'm not
really comfortable with this bill as is
even though I applaud the hard work that
went into it just U I'm not sure U I'm
not sure I'm not sure whether it's worth
it just to send a message and also like
enforceability was kind of hard so it's
kind of hard how the state of New
Hampshire is going to enforce uh you
know this law against somebody who's
operating in another state or another
another country so that's um so I'm not
sure exactly who this can be enforced
against unless um so that's and also of
course um also of course then the uh you
know also of course you can also like
probably say this is under the laws of
such and such a jurisdiction other than
New Hampshire and that also kind of cuts
this this the state and its ability to
enforce this law down so that's um I
just so I I'm not like uh so I just I
just s hesitate I just hesitate to uh
support this at this time but so and I
know that's kind of disappointing U you
know the chair and the ranking member
who work very hard at this and we're
very eager to do something about it and
also of course have some bipartisanship
but I'm certainly glad we're doing
something about it and being bipartisan
and I know we certainly can't rely much
on Washington right now they're kind
of they're kind of in a strange place so
anyway that's all I have to say than all
right any other comments representative
stap yeah thank you Mr chair um just to
cap off uh what I presented before the
Bia letter was dated November 7th with
their opposition opinion and of course
your recent amendment of November 14th
so I'm wondering if the Bia may have
revised any of uh their position on that
did I may have missed something if there
was anything between the 7th and the
14th I I not not to me as far as I I
have not seen anything at least as far
as I recall um and I and I did you know
I did check my emails this morning and I
don't recall receiving anything thank
you any representative Smith
anything all right um then I'm
uh I'm going to uh recognize uh
motion thank you um Mr chair um as to
House Bill
314 I would move or to pass as amend
2463 I will second that motion um
representative Smith do you wish to
speak to the motion beyond what we've
already
said it it's hard to know uh whether I
should or not because on the one hand
there are people who may be watching and
you want to have a complete record we
have spent a lot of time in this
committee on this bill and we've tried
to
um uh balance consumer
rights
issues and
business OB using business in the you
know broad sense business um obligations
and
rights what HB
314 does is
provide
additional information privacy
protections that apply to Providers of
information and services but not
Goods um so those are places like social
media companies internet service
landline anybody's still has a landline
and cell phone companies streaming
services email Banks all of the
financial
institutions um those
companies have personal information
about an individual and they need to in
order to carry out their business
functions what they do not need to do
however is to use that information for
marketing
purposes or anything else that meets
um that might meet the desires of the
business but have nothing at all to do
with the reason the consumer enters into
a relationship with that business
and this bill requires the individual to
opt in so you want to you want to you
don't care and you say yeah okay um all
the cookies go ahead I mean whether
they're chocolate chip or almond
whatever all the cookies um but that is
up to the individual and we in this
state care about individual rights um
and
um and these businesses who were covered
carry a lot of sensitive
information and they should be held to a
higher standard than businesses that are
just selling Goods
government's
requests that are appropriate um and
um one other important change and then
I'll I'll end is that when this bill
began wending its way through the
legislative process it considered very
very important a private right of
action and in trying to balance
competing needs completing goals
whatever
um the amendment that comes to you today
has no private right of action and it is
the attorney general with exclusive
enforcement rights and I mentioned this
as one of M examples of how On The Tight
RPP of keeping this as narrow and
focused as possible I think we did all
that we could do and I would hope that
my colleagues would join me in
supporting the amendment and and the
Bill thank you Mr
chair thank you uh other
comments yes representative
Andrew thank you Mr chair I am not
totally comfortable with this
bill because I would like to see data
from the other states that have already
put this into law but I know that's
impossible because a lot some of them
are only went into effect this year but
I'm going to vote in favor of the bill
because I believe this a bill of this
magnitude belongs on the house Flo floor
in debate thank
you other comments representative
Stapleton I had concerns uh relative to
what I presented with from the Bia and I
nicb but I think you've answered most of
that um and given that this is a
bipartisan support in the motions and
there's been good arguments made and
expressions and examples of um how this
bill Works to protect the consumer um
I'm willing to give it a shot and I'm
going to support it other other
comments and I I guess I would just want
to make the final comment and I want to
express my uh my thanks to all the
people who have given input to this and
in particular I want to express my
thanks to former representative Kirk and
to current representative Earth for uh
their uh sticking with us through this
long Hall of getting done I think that
um we've uh We've uh made a number of
changes that represent compromises in
many cases but I think that the the
final bill is something I think that we
can all be proud of and so I'm happy to
support it any other
comments all right I think we're ready
toh call the rooll on this is on the uh
ought to pass as
am with Amendment 2463 so this is a vote
on the amend Amendment on the amend
First Amendment
first thank you Mr chairman re Andrews
yes rep
testerman rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes
rep gon yes clerk votes yes re Melvin
yes rep pusk yes rep Ren Zulo
yes rep Smith yes rep Horgan um yes on
the amendment rep D Lorenzo yes rep
Kenny yes rep pagee
yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes rep
tur yes chairman Lynn
otpa any any further discussion before
we uh call the rooll on the main motion
of
otpa all right I'd ask the clerk then to
call the
role rep Andrews yes rep
testerman rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes
rep gon yes clerk votes yes rep Melvin
yes rep pusk yes rep renzullo yes rep
Smith yes rep Horgan no rep D Lorenzo
yes rep Kenny yes rep page
yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes rep
nay
um you on the regular
calendar I think we should put this on
the regular regular calendar
um will there be um I since I already in
anticipation have a draft report ready
to go and since we have a short deadline
I would volunteer to write the report um
for the majority representative Oregon
will there be a Minority Report I'll
wave my right to The Minority Report so
actually would have been happy to have
it go go in consent but understand that
so yes I so no I'm not going to bother
with that all right so it will not go on
consent but there will be no Minority
Report um is there any other business uh
that we need to
discuss seeing on the bill or anything
well you want to close the executive
session on the bill no that's a good
idea I'll close the executive session on
this on House Bill 314 and um is there
anything else that needs to be taken up
yes representative Smith yes um U Mr
chair it is likely that this is the last
time this session that that we will be
together um and uh only to return again
to work together in
January um and I would like to thank you
Mr chair for your leadership in this
first session and and then behind that
thank all of my colleagues as we talk
with people on other
committees um and follow uh their work
through the session some committees are
working hard and working well and some
committees are having difficulties in
coming together and trying to uh address
the issues of the common good and with
your leadership I think there has never
been a raised voice there has never been
um
uh a violation of
diplomatic and adult exchange of
ideas including ideas that are that many
of us hold dear and that are full of
conflict and um I think that it has
nothing to do with your judicial
training it has to do with your demeanor
and I would like to thank you and I
would imagine that everyone on the
committee
that thank thank you so much I really am
very honored for all of you to say that
I think this is a wonderful committee
and i' I've I've enjoyed uh I've enjoyed
it immensely and uh I think we've done
some really good work on a lot on a
whole lot of things um and where we've
disagreed we've disagreed respectfully
and and I think that's that's really
important U so again thank you I wish
every everybody a a very Happy
Thanksgiving and happy holiday season
and we'll uh see you all next year right
thank
you